a major breakthrough in the search for a
covet 19 vaccine
johnson and johnson revealing overnight
it protects monkeys after just one dose
human trials of that vaccine begin today
as covid19 related deaths now top 150
000 in the u.s
wow and there are now more than 4.4
million total cases
uh seven states reporting a record high
number of deaths in a single day
let's bring in deborah burks dr deborah
burks white house
corona virus her response coordinator dr
burks always
great to see you the word is that you
say i'm worried about the south
but i'm really about the midwest where
so just to remind everyone across the
south
still a very serious pandemic although
they're starting to see the glimmers of
hope of
improvement and we really want to thank
all the governors and mayors who've
worked very hard with their populations
to ensure everyone was wearing mass
decreasing social gatherings decreasing
gatherings in spaces where you cannot
social distance like bars
and decreasing parties at home where you
can't social distance
so now we see the virus probably because
of vacations and other reasons of travel
moving up into kentucky tennessee
southern ohio
missouri iowa kansas nebraska and of
course we continue to have problems
across the west coast washington
oregon california idaho and utah and now
increases in colorado
so these are the these are the states
that we call yellow states
we believe if the governors and mayors
of every locality right now
would mandate mass for their communities
and every american would wear a mask and
socially distance
and not congregate in large settings
where you can't socially distance or
wear a mask
that we can really get control of this
virus and drive down cases as arizona
has done
dr burke's this is exciting news what
we're reporting with johnson
johnson giving the drug the vaccine to
the monkeys and it works on the first
try
what do you know about this what more
can you tell us well the exciting thing
about the johnson and johnson vaccine
now remember we have two moving into
phase three trials
right now from moderna and pfizer the
johnson and johnson
all of these vaccines were built on what
we call
known technology are known vectors so we
knew the safety of those to begin with
the johnson and johnson vaccine is
exciting because it's a single dose
and so you get one dose and to be able
to show protection in monkeys
like the other vaccines have shown with
two doses
does shorten the time period for
development because your readout becomes
30 days quicker
doctor your colleague dr fauci has
suggested recently that
goggles would work even better or in
addition to
you're talking about masks people have
come around to the reality of that
are we are we going to look at more
demands based on what dr fauci has said
well i've seen really great face shields
and i've seen them around the country
you know i've been out to 14 states the
administration
sent me out to all of the hot spots and
then to the yellow states to really
deliver specific messages about how to
improve and prevent
spread in their communities and i've
gotten to see a lot of exciting face
masks out there
and face masks that come from the bottom
up and i think that's really i think
people the american people are
innovative
those are actually pretty easy and
straightforward to make many
universities
and those who have printers are making
face shields now
so these 3d printers can really increase
that production and i think others are
making them
and they can be decorated so dr well
no one's really interested in
decorations i want to know whether face
shields or goggles is something we're
going to hear next
uh is is this something that suddenly is
going to become the new guideline
so here's the thing about the face
shield in addition to the mask the mask
is to protect others is to block those
droplets
and block that contamination that
happens when you speak or sing or talk
or even breathe the thing about the face
shields we think that that could protect
the individuals
and that it would decrease the ability
for them to touch their eyes and spread
virus
as well as those droplets coming towards
them
so they're two different technologies
for two different reasons
unbelievable uh because we also heard
now that
the masks not only protect people from
you but you also helps you with your
protection
so from don't wear a mask to wear a mask
to now it can help you if it spread and
now could help you
block and now you're saying wear goggles
it's unbelievable all right um let's get
kids back to school
do you believe from what you know
even in the hottest spot there's a way
to get kids back to school safely being
that their transmission
uh is so low the chances of them getting
it
is so small well first let's go back to
those two statistics
one we don't we know from examples
around the country that children do get
infected
what we do know is they do better by and
large
the question about whether they are less
transmissive
transmit the virus less is still on an
open debate we have one study it's not
done in the united states and i think
that still is an open question
when you're talking about putting
children back in school the teachers the
grandparents that are home
and multi-generational can i stop you
there i heard i mean we've heard from
experts who said it's almost impossible
for kids to spread this
to other kids and to adults you're
saying that's not true at all
we have that one study in south korea
which showed
that precise fact what i can't tell you
is in united states do i have an example
positive or negative that confirms that
study and i think you know with
scientists we like to have
always more than one study to confirm it
what we do know
is children particularly children under
18
get much less sick as well as people
under 35
that means also that they're more what
we call asymptomatic
and more likely to spread the virus
without them knowing that they have
symptoms what we can do as americans if
we want our children back in school
is we can help this country by everybody
doing what the president has asked
wear a mask socially distance avoid
gatherings where you cannot socially
distance and wear a mask
like bars and house parties and this
will bring down these case numbers
very rapidly if we all together as
americans did those few things
after i get it i'd we'd love to have ten
studies on that right now but school's
coming
it's a month out and the doctor is six
months and the doc and doctors uh
the president has asked that school's
open so
is the guidance going to be hey follow
all these protocols and measures but get
kids back in school the cdc has put out
those guidelines so that children can go
back to school
i think every school districts around
the country and certainly we have
multiple school districts where the
test positivity is under two percent and
we have a whole another set of school
districts and counties where it's less
than five percent and case counts are
extraordinarily low
what we want is the whole country to be
able to go back to school
and all of those case counts down to
what we call the green states and we
know that is possible because
states have been able to do that and
maintain that so that's the evidence
base that we should be talking about
we have an evidence now of what works
and how to maintain
very low case counts the rest of america
needs to follow those guidelines and
bring the rest of us
into that green category dr burke let's
talk about hydrochloroquine
because the president was saying that
it's worked for some people there was
that
local congresswoman that said it saved
her life and um
then you recently had the video of the
doctors i believe it was in texas that
all the social media sites took down the
video because she was saying
this is this could be a cure um this has
helped every single patient i've treated
not one of my patients has died because
i've put them on hydroxyl chloroquine
the zpac and zinc so why is this
pharmacy board in ohio why are they
banning it if it does work in certain
cases
science and medicine has always been
full of accounts like this
and that's why you do randomize clinical
trials
to actually be able to compare patient
to patient
everything that you just reported on had
no controls
in those individual practices we know in
the randomized controlled
trials to date and there's been several
of them
that there's not evidence that it
improves those patients outcomes
whether they have mild moderate disease
or whether they're seriously ill in the
hospital
medicine always has these reports and
that's why we do these randomized
controlled trials
there also may be a specific subgroup
that does benefit
but we can't see those in these
randomized controls
isn't that up to the doctor what if my
doctor says hydrochloric and what if uh
your doctor says redesire
isn't that up to or or
hydroxychloroquine is it that up to my
doctor to decide not a pharmacy board to
just ban it across the board
well let's separate those two issues we
did have a randomized control
trial with rendezvir it does work the
president's been very clear and given me
very clear direction to get that out to
every single state in an equitable way
so that every american can have that
advantage of receiving rendez-severe
when they
first get to the hospital and can
benefit the most and so
that is moving forward i medical boards
decide for their state based on clinical
practices
and so i'm assuming that ohio had a very
specific reason in order to take this
approach
every state has to be able to look at
this independently because that's how we
are we're state driven for those kind of
decision making
all right dr deborah burks thank you
very much for your time this morning we
appreciate it thanks dr burks
thank you